hi there Steve Kaufman here so it's week
two our 12 week or 90 day challenge
today I want to talk about the
importance of varying your activities in
order that you don't get bogged down or
feel frustrated and one of the ways that
we keep track of your level of
activities of course is the coins the
coins are because you get coins for
different kinds of activities therefore
you want to be accumulating as many
coins is kind of an indicator a
milestone of how active you are and of
course the more active you are the
faster you're gonna learn but if you're
always doing the same thing it gets a
bit boring I once had a boss at work who
told me it's a long road that has no
curves we need a little bit of variety
and so you can vary the content and I
have spoken in the past about what I
call the short term activities which is
really working the basic structures of
the language and that's something that
is featured a lot in our mini stories
the most common phrases the most common
structures but on the other hand you
want to move forward into more difficult
authentic content where you are
acquiring more words and of course the
linking activity itself you can deal
with it in different ways one thing that
linking does is it enables you to look
up a word add it to your database you'll
come across that again it's highlighted
in yellow gradually gradually as you if
you review through flashcards you don't
have to do but it's another activity
that you can use you slowly move that to
where it becomes a part of your
initially passive vocabulary and
possibly active vocabulary so you need
to acquire these new yellow links but
even in content that you have already
studied and this is something I point
out in the workshop that I did
day you can go back into material that
you looked at three four five months ago
that you think you know you'll discover
there lo and behold there are words that
you thought you knew that you don't know
link them again don't feel concerned
about moving words to knowledge because
you're afraid you might forget them
again or that they will no longer be
known it doesn't matter you come across
them again you're not sure what they
mean you link them again another thing
that I find very useful when I go
through something for that tenth timing
is to create phrases because the phrase
is embody and the structure the grammar
of the language and the goal of course
is not to be trying to remember the
rules all the time but to find certain
phrasing natural and its natural its
meaning immediately and it just feels
natural that that's the way you say it
and if you read it and listen to it and
find it in different situations often
enough you will be able to produce that
as well so I think today in our second
week I want to emphasize that you should
vary your activities certainly do all
the different activities that are gonna
earn coins but also be flexible and
creative and how you use your links
don't worry too much about moving
something to know that you're gonna then
forget make sure you introduce enough
variety of activities enough variety of
content so the experience remains fresh
for you because the brain requires both
repetition and novelty so keep it new
keep it fresh very things be flexible
and don't get frustrated like as I today
I had a conversation in Arabic I
struggled mightily to speak in Arabic
probably worse than I did three weeks
ago and this is all going to be part of
your learning you'll do better some days
than other days and yet as long as you
stay
that you will over time improve that's
kind of what language learning is light
and the goal of eventually being humble
able to understand and connect with
different cultures and to communicate
makes it all worthwhile
so there you have it week two by canal